Welcome back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
work on the following problem.
Which is we begin with a
vector field, capital F,
that is z*x*i plus
z*y*j plus x*k.
And we're going to
look at the curve
C that is a helix, that we can
describe by the parameter t.
So we'll describe it as
cosine t comma sine t comma t.
And we're interested
in the portion
of the helix that goes from
(1, 0, 0) to (minus 1, 0, pi).
And I'd like you to do two
things with this problem.
The first thing
I'd like you to do
is I'd like you to sketch
the curve that is carved out
when you follow the t
values that will start you
at (1, 0, 0) and will finish
you up at (minus 1, 0, pi).
The second thing I
would like you to do
is I would like you to compute
the line integral F dot dr
over that portion of the helix.
So there are two
parts to this problem.
Why don't you pause the video,
work on these two parts,
and then when you're
feeling comfortable
seeing the solution,
bring the video back up
and I'll show you how I did it.
OK, welcome back.
So again what we're interested
in doing in this problem is
first, understanding
what the curve looks
like that we want to take
this line integral over.
And then actually computing
the line integral.
So we have this
C that is a helix
and it's described by
cosine t, sine t, t.
And in fact-- well, I won't
say any more about this helix.
But it actually
should remind you
when you see the picture of some
portion of what DNA looks like.
It's going to spiral
around, just the way
some little side of-- if you
take DNA, how it spirals up,
it's going to be the
boundary of some of that.
So we'll see that momentarily.
And if you notice, the
first thing that's helpful
if you want to
sketch the curve, is
that t-- I know immediately
what the parameters are in t.
t is ranging from 0 to pi.
So I know already exactly
what I want to do.
And in order to draw this
curve, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to give myself
a frame of reference.
Because otherwise
it's going to be
really hard to draw this curve.
And the frame of reference
is the following.
All of these points, all
of the points cosine t,
sine t, t, lie-- in the x-y
distance from the origin,
they lie at a radius 1.
So in terms of x
and y, they're all
going to sit on the boundary
of a cylinder of radius 1.
So let me draw
what I mean by that
and then we'll see
where the points are.
So let me actually come
write right over here.
So my first part
sketching the curve,
the first thing I'm going to
do is give myself a cylinder.
Which I'll show you is
of radius 1 momentarily.
And I'm going to actually say
this is the z-axis, coming
straight through the middle.
And then the y-axis is going
to come out the side, as usual.
And the x-axis is going to
come down in this direction.
OK, so this cylinder I'm
thinking of, it has radius 1.
So at any given z
value, any fixed z
value that I intersect
with the cylinder gives
a circle of radius 1.
Now if you notice
again, what I was
trying to explain
from over here,
is that if I don't look at
the z component, obviously
the cosine t, sine
t is something
that's on the unit circle
if I ignore the z component.
And so that's how I know that
these x and y values here
are just going to
lie on the cylinder,
because they're always
distance 1 from the z-axis,
at any given height.
So that's the first
thing I observe.
The second thing I observe
is that I mentioned
t goes from 0 to pi, and that's
exactly the z values also.
So the z values are
going from 0 to pi,
so I know my first value is
going to be on the xy-plane.
And my last value is going to
be on the z equals pi plane.
And then the last
thing to observe
is that what is being carved
out in the x and y components?
Well, it's really
exactly what you
would do if you were trying
to parameterize a circle.
But you're
parameterizing a circle
and instead of just
drawing it always
on the same z
plane-- so xy-plane,
z equals a constant-- you're
parameterizing that circle
and you're also moving up.
And so the first value (1, 0,
0) is happening somewhere here.
And the last value is
happening at negative 1, 0, pi.
And so I have to go sort of
in the backwards direction.
So here's my x equals
negative 1, 0, pi.
And so I'm kind of behind.
You should think
of this as being--
let me see if I can draw
this-- this is behind the pi--
maybe I should draw
it a little further.
If this is the pi height, it
was more like right there.
It's behind the z-axis here.
It's on the other side.
And so the curve
that's carved out
is going to look
something like this.
It's going to come
up through here.
It's spiraling.
And then it's
going to go behind,
on the other side of the
cylinder, and spiral up.
Now in a perfect world, if
I could draw this actually
in three dimensions, the way
it's coming up is actually,
it has to have some
sort of constant rate.
Because it's always
moving in the z direction
at a constant rate.
It's moving in the z
direction linearly.
Maybe this picture is not
the most perfect picture
because it looks like it's
going up really fast at the end.
But it gives us a feel
for how the curve looks.
If I continued it, it would
come back around to the front
by the time t went to 2*pi.
And so this is a spiral.
It goes around the cylinder,
behind the cylinder.
And then if I go for
another pi, from pi to 2*pi,
it's going to go-- continue to
curve around and then come back
out to the front and be
right above this point.
So that's the helix.
That's the shape of the helix.
So this is an
approximate sketch.
Good thing I said
sketch the curve.
So this is a sketch
of the curve.
And now what we
want to do, again
as I mentioned, is we want
to compute a line integral,
we want to compute F
dot dr over this curve.
So what I'm going
to need is I'm going
to know that this
is the curve here,
and I need to understand how to
parameterize F and dr in terms
of this parameter t.
So that's what
I'm interested in.
So let's think about what F
dot dr is in order to do this.
I think the notation
you've seen from lecture
is F we usually denote by
capital P, capital Q, capital
R. And dr we denote
[dx, dy,  dz].
And so F dot dr, as
we've seen previously,
is P*dx plus Q*dy plus R*dz.
So let's see what that is
in the parameters we have.
So let me first
remind ourselves, x
in this situation is cosine t.
y is sine t.
And z is equal to t.
Based on how we're
parameterizing the curve.
And we're interested in the
values of t going from 0 to pi.
So these are the quantities
that we're going to need.
Now in order to solve this
problem I need dx, dy, dz.
I also need P, Q, and R in terms
of these x, y, and z values.
So let me remind you also--
I'm going to write it over here
so I don't have to look again--
F is actually z*x comma z*y
comma x.
Let me check that.
Yes, that is what I have.
So that is my F. So now that
I have it a little closer,
I'm going to put
it all together.
And I actually have to move
over to put it together,
but now the reference is closer.
So notice first I'm
going to do P*dx.
So P is z times x.
And then what is dx?
Well, dx-- I really need to
figure out what dx/dt is,
right? dx/dt is negative sine t.
And so I'm going to replace
the dx by a negative sine t dt.
I'll be replacing
dy by cosine t dt
and I'll be replacing dz by dt.
So I have all the pieces here; I
just have to put them together.
So let me do that.
I want to integrate over C
F dot dr. I'm really going
to be integrating-- let's see.
Let me come to this side so
I can see everything I need.
I'm really going
to be integrating--
I know I'm integrating from
0 to pi in my parameter t.
My first component of
F I told you was z*x.
So that's t cosine t, and
then dx is, as I said,
negative sine t dt.
So times negative sine t dt.
That's my first component.
My next component,
as I said, is Q*dy.
Q was z*y and so it's t sine t.
And then dy is cosine t dt.
Oops, let me put the dt
there, it's a little easier.
And then I'm going to write
the last component here,
so we can see it
all in one frame.
And then the last
thing was R*dz.
And R is just x.
So that's cosine t.
And dz is just dt.
So there's three components.
This was the P*dx component,
this is the Q*dy component,
and this is the R*dz component.
And so notice, this is great.
This is why I like this
problem, it's going to be nice.
Because I've got a t cosine
t times negative sine t,
and a t sine t times a cosine t.
And so these two add
up to 0, and so I only
have to integrate one thing.
So I only have to integrate
from 0 to pi cosine t dt.
And so what do I get?
I get-- this should be sine
t evaluated at 0 and pi.
And sine of pi I believe is 0.
And sine of 0 I believe is 0.
And so I get 0
minus 0, so I get 0.
So they're actually--
when I compute
the line integral of F
dot dr over that helix,
I actually get 0.
So let me just remind
you, real quick,
what the point of the
problem was and what we did.
We had-- at the very beginning,
we had a vector field,
we had a curve, and
essentially all we were doing
is a problem we've done in two
dimensions many times, which
is compute a line
integral along a curve.
And so we just
added a dimension.
The problem is exactly the same.
Instead of now just dx and dy,
now we have a dx, dy, and a dz.
We have one extra
direction you're moving.
But that's all that's different.
So the first thing we
did was sketch the curve.
Then we computed the line
integral, as I'm saying,
by exactly the same methods
that we did in two dimensions.
So everything, really,
should remind you
of what you've done
previously, we now just
have a third component
we have to deal with.
And that was, in our case, in
this problem, the R*dz part.
So I think that's
where I'll stop.